EVERY DAY THAT THIS CONTINUES,
IT COMES AT A STAGGERING COST TO
THE UKRAINIAN PEOPLE.
WE DO HAVE SOME NEW VIDEO JUST
IN TO CNN THAT SHOWS IMMENSE
DAMAGE TO THE THEATER OF
MARIUPOL BEING USED AS A BOMB
SHELTER FOR CIVILIANS.
THIS WAS STRUCK BY A RUSSIAN AIR
STRIKE LAST WEDNESDAY.
CITY OFFICIALS NOW REPORT 300
PEOPLE ARE BELIEVED TO HAVE DIED
IN THAT ATTACK.
300 PEOPLE IN THAT ATTACK.
THE NEXT VIDEO WE'LL PLAY FOR
YOU SHOWS THE MOMENTS
IMMEDIATELY AFTER THE BOMB AS
PEOPLE TRIED TO ESCAPE THE
DESTRUCTION.
WATCH THIS?
>> YOU CAN SEE PEOPLE COVERED IN
DUST AND DEBRIS.
HOLES IN THE WALLS AS PEOPLE TRY
IT MAKE THEIR WAY DOWN A
STAIRCASE TO LEAVE THE HEAVILY
DAMAGED BUILDING.
REMEMBER, THE WORD CHILDREN WAS
WRITTEN OUTSIDE, CLEARLY IN
LETTERS THAT YOU COULD SEE FROM
THE AIR AND NOW WE'RE LEARNING
AT LEAST 300 PEOPLE KILLED IN
THAT DEVASTATING ATTACK.
WANT TO GO TO CNN SENIOR
INTERNATIONAL CORRESPONDENT
FREDERIK PLEITGEN ON THE GROUND
IN KYIV.
AND, FRED, IT JUST -- IT IS
REALLY UPSETTING TO SEE THAT
DAMAGE, TO SEE THE SUFFERING OF
THE PEOPLE AS THEY TRY TO GET
OUT.
ONE OF THEM EVEN SAID THAT ONE
OF THE BOMBS HIT THE AREA WHERE
PEOPLE WERE GOING TO GET WATER.
>> Reporter: YEAH, YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT, JOHN.
IT IS DEVASTATING VIDEO.
AND VERY TRAUMATIZING VIDEO AS
WELL THAT WE'RE SEEING THERE FOR
FIRST TIME FROM INSIDE THAT
THEATER THAT GOT HIT IN
MARIUPOL.
AND I THINK ONE OF THE
DEVASTATING THINGS ALSO ABOUT
THIS DEATH TOLL WE'RE HEARING
NOW IS THAT THE CITY COUNCIL,
THE MUNICIPAL COUNCIL THERE IN
MARIUPOL, WHICH IS BARELY
FUNCTIONING BECAUSE THAT CITY IS
UNDER SIEGE, AND CONTINUES TO BE
HIT BY RUSSIAN AIR POWER AND
RUSSIAN ROCKETS, IS THAT THEY
SAY THEY BASE THAT ON HAVING
SPOKEN TO PEOPLE, THAT MANAGED
TO GET OUT OF THAT THEATER
BECAUSE THEY THEMSELVES CAN'T
ACTUALLY SEND ANY SORT OF RESCUE
CREWS INTO THAT.
IT HAS BEEN ABOUT A WEEK SINCE
THAT THEATER WAS HIT, SIMPLY
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE ANY, ALL
OF THE EMERGENCY SERVICES IN
THAT CITY ARE NOT WORKING
ANYMORE BECAUSE OF THE
DEVASTATING SITUATION.